[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: It used to
be that if you were an AdMob
Publisher, you
got AdMob Reports.
And if you were a
Firebase Developer,
you got Google
Analytics for Firebase.
But recently, Firebase
and AdMob got together
and built a link between
their two systems.
So AdMob Reporting now comes
with Firebase user metrics
like session length
baked right in.
And Firebase looks like it
just found a big bag of money
because its financial
stats, like lifetime value
and revenue per user,
now include AdMob income.
Plus there's a new
ad exposure metric,
events for clicks and
impressions, and a bunch more.
This kind of intelligence
is something you really
can't get anywhere
else, and it's
easy to take advantage
of the combined
power of AdMob and Firebase.
Just link your AdMob app
to a Firebase project,
get the config file,
and make sure you
are using the right CocoaPods
or Gradle artifacts.
That's it.
Just rebuild and deploy
and watch the data roll
into Analytics and AdMob.
So give it a try.
[MUSIC PLAYING]